- I don't really know
what artisanal means.
Uh.
- I don't know what it means either,
but I'm totally a sucker for it.
(upbeat music)
(whooshing and creaking)
- I'm not going to lie, I
don't really buy groceries.
I go shopping like once a month
and I just eat out all the time
and I have a horrible lifestyle.
- I think it tastes the same.
- I think it would taste better.
(laughing)
- I know it tastes better.
- I don't like pickles.
- Really?
- Number one's salty.
- Tastes like stuff I have with.
- Can I just eat the rest of it?
- With my hot dog.
- Super pickle-y.
- Right, yeah, this is good.
- I feel like it's been sitting
in a jar for a long time.
- I think these pickles.
- It's so sour.
- Have touched other foods.
Which is why I'm inclined
to think artisanal.
- Number two.
- This one has a much richer green.
- Yeah.
- Almost a fake looking green.
- This one looks more special.
- Yeah.
- It's more colorful.
- Interesting, this tastes maybe better?
- Mm.
- This one's better.
- But that could be the preservatives.
- I think this one's artisanal.
- I'm going to go with two.
- I'm going to say two is artisanal.
- My vote's for number two.
- I say number two also.
(cash register bell ringing)
- No!
- Yeah!
Cause this one looks more like organic.
- No!
- Number one?
- Okay, I, we're just failing at it.
(groaning)
- Okay, good, that makes sense.
- Oh, okay, well it smells like mayo.
- We did just eat mayonnaise with a spoon.
- It's so warm.
(gagging and coughing)
- This is so oily.
It just tastes like olive
oil and mayo mixed together.
- I'm definitely leaning towards
this one as the artisanal one.
There's just a more,
more density of flavors.
Number two!
- That tastes much better.
- Yeah, this one two is better.
Two!
- Two is better and two is
the one that we've always had.
- It doesn't smell like anything.
That's weird.
- Lots of high fructose
corn syrup in here.
(laughing)
- See this one, I was just
going to go back for seconds.
- Mm.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Artisanal.
- Yeah.
- Number one.
- Yeah, one is artisanal.
- Right.
(cash register bell ringing)
- Thank you, yes!
(clapping)
- Alright.
- Yay!
(clapping)
- Ooo.
- Oo, yum!
- Okay, so what are we, what
are we looking for here?
Artisanal maple syrup probably
smells more like maple trees.
- Okay.
- Wow, that's like rich.
- It tastes typical to me.
- I don't know, it just was like.
- I like it, I mean so
far I would say this
is the more expensive one
because you can sort of taste the maple.
- Yeah.
- Oh crap.
(laughing)
- This is spicier.
- Yeah, that's definitely
sweeter than the other one.
- Hmm.
- I'm ashamed to say I
can't tell the difference.
- This one is also delicious.
- This is also really good.
- This one has a little
more Auntie Jemima.
- Okay.
- Feel to it.
- I think,
definitely one.
- I'm just going with one,
because two has these weird bubbles in it.
- I think two is artisanal.
- Two.
Yeah.
- I'm going to say number
one is the expensive one.
(cash register bell ringing)
(groaning)
- Two is the artisanal one.
- Dah!
Damn it.
- Oo!
- [Together] What?
- I do like organic ketchup
more than regular ketchup.
- So, this should be easy for you.
- Should be.
(laughing)
- Hopefully.
- So, number one.
- It's got a real high surface tension.
- This is a red 40 dye right there.
(laughing)
- Yes.
- At it's best.
- It tastes like ketchup.
- Yeah.
- McDonald's ketchup.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, it tastes sour.
- It's like sour ketchup.
- Sour, acid.
- Oh, processed food is horrible.
That is what I'm learning through this.
- Mm hmm.
- I mean, it's not going to
change my diet, that's just.
- Where as this one's thicker.
- How about this?
- It's thicker, it's
got this mottled texture
rather than eerily smooth..
- Better after taste.
- This tastes like tomato
sauce a little bit.
- It does taste like tomato sauce
and it stays in your mouth.
- Yeah.
- That is not good.
- I sort of, I like it actually.
- You like that?
- Yeah.
- This is in a bottle
and it has the words ketchup on the front.
No way.
- Should we do two?
- I choose two.
- I like number one, but I know
number two is the right one,
that's more expensive.
- Okay.
I vote number two also.
- Yeah.
- I think two is artisanal.
(cash register bell ringing)
- Woo!
- Yay!
(clapping)
- I grew up eating this,
but the artisanal one
tastes much better.
- Yeah.
- I feel better eating it.
- I like the regular
store bought ones better.
I think because I'm used to it.
- One day I'll be very rich
and I'll only buy organic food
and organic peanut
butter from Whole Foods,
but that's not, my current life.
- And hang out with Kourtney Kardashian.
- Rhianna.
- I'll always pay more because it's like,
"Oh, I read about it in a fancy magazine."
"You have to get the good ketchup."
(whooshing)
(creaking)